we are at the beginning of uh
of the coverte era and we are going to
see them all around us all the time and
everywhere
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this episode is all about robotics meet
amnon avigai a well-experienced manager
in the fields of i.t organizational
processes and automation
i'm known as the general manager of
robotize the robotics division of mitwa
amnon established robotized two years
ago together with amir matwak the
company's business development manager
now after two extensive years amnon and
robotize are recognized in the israeli
market as market leaders in the cobatic
fields
you know the world is obviously changing
uh so rapidly and the way that we a lot
of the tasks a lot of the things that we
need to interact with our physical world
um you know they have a we we're
constantly now thinking of what
previously seemed like science fiction
today is already becoming a reality
partially due to robotizing different
solutions that you bring to the world
and so i'm looking forward to talking
about robotics with you both on the on
the creation perspective but then also
on the integration with humanity in the
human computer interaction if you will
and so thank you very much for joining
me today
great great being here and uh yeah it is
very interesting and uh
um
yeah it is very interesting to share our
thoughts and and the the way we think
that the world will uh
be and become with the cobots serving us
yeah
so so already off the bat you're
mentioning um the term cobots
um and not robots so what what is it
what is a cobot
okay so so actually the the
term the word a robot
was invented at i think it was 1921
when a czech a author uh
looked for a
word that will describe a machine that
is doing a hard label and he uh took it
from you know it sounds like
robota in in russian but it is from the
the czech language which which is a hard
work
um
and and uh
you know we we
think that the word robot exists since
ever no it exists since in 1921
and um
uh
the the the actual robots that we we
we started to use
started you know in the
beginning of the
of the 80s of the last century when uh
mainly
japanese manufacturers
use the
robots in the
production lines of cars
but those were
mainly robotic
arms that they
no human could they be around it because
you know it could hit them so uh we
we had
robots like you know machines they did
hard work
uh
but uh the term cobot
reflects the a machine which is
collaborative with human beings
so this is why we call it the cobot
collaborative robot uh because it can
interact and they move and they
act around the human beings
um so just to make sure that we
because you know in today's world we
still you know if we're following tech
crunch or various newsletters we'll get
exposed to them but in in reality today
where will we find these cobots you know
if if we're looking at the general
humanity
where would i find today the
implementation of production cobots
okay so so you know first of all three
three uh main technologies had to be
ready and
developed in order that we will have a
cobots
working cobots
first one is energy you know all robots
use
uh um batteries and we need the the
batteries you know like in in
liking cars that the batteries will have
enough energy that will last for a long
time and that will be charged rapidly
and the second is is computing now the
each robot has a lot of sensors that
they
bring a lot of information and that
information should be uh
processed uh
near
real time and you know when to
reflect on the cobot
positioning or how it behaves uh and and
the third is the navigation you know uh
all the cobots you know they they move
uh autonomously and
they need to navigate you know in in
places that
they didn't know until uh recently so uh
uh so those are the three uh
technologies navigation computing and
and energy and we we can
you know when we deploy nowadays cobots
it is
anywhere that you can imagine of it
starts from our homes
uh in hospitals in factories in
hotels in restaurants nearly everywhere
and
since the cobot can move a
autonomously from one point two to the
other they can you can
only imagine
all the
applications that we can install on on
those machines and so
so
very interesting but you know if we're
looking now at the implementation and
the integration of robots there must be
some fundamental
fundamental premises or assumptions that
these robots need to fulfill beyond
their ability to conduct
some a task what are some of the i don't
know safety
and you know um
understanding wide expectations of such
a robot i mean because at the end this
this cobot is going to be implemented in
a physical space right and so we must
have some universal agreement as to what
we're allowed and what we're not allowed
to
to have the robot perform you know on an
algorithmic level so are there any
standards that are sort of universal in
this matter
um great question no standards okay
until now no no standards and i i'm sure
you know regulation is always
behind the
technology so uh
just a few steps behind yeah
few big steps yeah yeah
so there is no uh
instant
standards about the how a cobot should
behave or not um
but the
the manufacturers and the
uh we as as a you know the integrators
and who are responsible uh for the
implementation of
the solution uh we
must
make sure that
no cobat will uh harm a human being
so it did this is you know uh
if we will uh have an incident in which
a cobot
caused
an injury or death to a human being i
think that
it will take a lot of time to convince
others to implement a robotic solutions
uh
even though you know why
moving
machines
that are being
driven by by
human beings
make a lot of accidents but still if a
machine that drives alone will will make
an accident then
this is an issue this is a big issue um
right but for instance we are sorry yeah
okay no because i i really am you know
fascinated that because as you're
standing at the forefront i want to make
sure we're devoting enough time to to a
conversation also about you know where
we're headed and what are the different
opportunities because while we while
there are companies that are dealing
with this i'm still struggling to really
understand
how how much of an impact is this going
to make on uh on on actually you know
everything around us and the way that we
live our life and so maybe you can share
with me just a little bit about about
robotize and and how you're thinking
through the vision of robots integrated
into our society okay so for for the
time being we are dealing with four kind
of applications the first one is a
cleaning
uh um cleaning robots you know those who
swap and and vacuum the floor or
sweep it or
or
brush it you know those kind of robots
the second
application is delivery
uh
robots we are now in the middle of uh
implementation of a solution in a
big factor in israel know that instead
of um
i i don't uh
oh instead of human
beings moving heavy stuff from
one
point to the other point in the factory
robots are going to to do it um
and so the first i was cleaning the
second one is delivery uh we are in the
middle of implementation of a
small delivery robot that will take uh
blood tests from one side of a
laboratory to the other side of
laboratory um
we
implemented a
disinfection robot based on a uvc
light uv light in a big factory of uh um
pharma factory and
the the fourth one is the telepresence
uh
yeah telepresence robots that no uh
helped me
being there without being the okay so
those are the four kinds of uh
solutions that we
provide right now
and so if you're looking at the way that
these are going to be implemented at
scale
how where are we today in terms of the
life cycle of you know either the the
experimental phase the phase where we're
ready to to grow and to have this be an
integration an integral part of of our
workforce where are we on this timeline
assuming that one day we will have you
know robots surrounding us constantly
yes so i think that we are only at the
beginning the very beginning and but
since the uh as i said
earlier um the technology is quite ready
uh we are facing we are going to face a
a boom you know where an explosion of
cobots and we see how many
uh
companies
come
one after
the other
some of the companies are coming from
the application side and some of the
companies are coming from the robotic
side um
yeah so
yeah we are at the beginning of
of the cobot era and we are going to see
them all around us all the time and
everywhere
fantastic now to share with me maybe a
little bit about the the development
process of of a robot like this from you
know from how you actually
get the the idea or the thesis as to how
this robot is going to be integrated all
the way to actually running the tests
and seeing how well it performs in a
real world situation so i'd love to hear
just you know an end-to-end process of
how building a robot like this you know
how does this take place
okay so so as i said we don't build the
the robot the robots are being made by
the companies that we are working with
uh and
in
we uh
we come to for instance let's say a
parking lot a big parking lot that they
now is being cleaned by a you a by
person that writes a cleaning machine
normally at night
how they work nobody wants to work
in those kind of works so we come to to
this parking lot
we inspect it and we map it
and
we bring the robot to the place actually
the uh the mapping is is being done by
the robot itself while riding it
uh manually uh and it builds a map using
a lidar a lidar
element uh
you know using a laser air beam
yeah
and
after mapping it we
sit
with the uh
owner of the parking lot and we build
with him the uh cleaning plan of
this parking lot um it can be
done
you know
normally in robots they use
one hour of charging for every one hour
of working so we get a a machine that
can work 12 hours a day
365 days a year uh you know being doing
this uh cleaning mission so this is for
for for cleaning if we go to uh in this
laboratory where that i spoke about
uh again the mapping is being done
always with the robot you know with the
lidar and and then we sit with the uh
with the uh
uh
people that run this laboratory and we
build the plan
how it will go from one point to the
other point and yeah
yeah so what it sounds is that there's
there's an element of of taking existing
solutions right taking the technology
understanding that it has you know
creating a general enough solution that
will provide for a variety of use cases
and then through an intimate work with
their organization you're able to then
actually make the fine fine tuning for
how this
cobot or robot is going to integrate
within the current chain of procedures
for this for the exact situation right
and how how how much do they vary how
how different do these organizations
work
in in terms of your having to fine-tune
the way that then the robot cooperates
with them um since we are working in
a lot of verticals uh
yeah
it is very a lot i mean a hospital is is
uh working in one
way and the factory is working in a
different way so
it is totally different the amount of
people that
are
working in a supermarket are not the
amount of people that are working in a
laboratory uh we have in a big store
in supermarkets in israel robots that
are that clean uh the the the
supermarkets and uh
um
you know if you try to activate the or
make the robot work uh in a
thursday afternoon
the robot will fail it will not
be able to accomplish the the mission
that it runs yeah
uh
where is your
your passion and excitement for robotics
coming from where you know you're
choosing to spend
your time you know with these robots and
and you know there's also the
interesting question of building them
and and creating the actual robot versus
the implementation and the actual field
and the integration
to humanity
what what what came into these decisions
for you um
actually it only started at the
beginning of the uh covered uh um
eruption
towards
them february
when we
installed um
remote patient monitoring solution in
hospitals in in the country
and one of the department managers
in one of the hospices came to me and
and asked me why do you
install
a fixed
solution on a wall
why can't you make something that we i
will be able to to guide from outside
the uh
the department uh or from home
and they
i said okay interesting i want to
investigate this
uh
and uh
you know it was only the beginning of of
uh the uh technology being ready uh
to do such a
such
missions
and and
we in in ten days we built a prototype
of a moving
robotic moving a remote patient
monitoring solution and
once we discovered
the technology we couldn't uh you know
uh uh
stop working
on it and it was you know we are quite
an old company robotize is part of a
company that exists uh
since 1906
uh
and and we started to act like you know
a startup
around around the clock you know
bringing new technologies understanding
new technologies uh and and we don't
stop you know
more and more solutions and more and
more uh
implementations
fantastic and uh i think that the the
world that we're talking about here is
you know what what i think that is so
fascinating in our point in time is that
we understand that we have the
technology
we understand from
perhaps an ethical and a moral
perspective that it's that you know with
the terminator fear that that maybe some
some folks have from the previous
generation that that's not what's
holding true
today and and the integration is going
to take place and i was just
a question of of when and where not an
if and so i'm really excited by
companies like robotized that commonly
and actually go to
uh to perform these integrations and and
push push them forward in humanity in
general and so i'm thank you very very
much this was a really really
interesting
best of luck with robotize continue
pushing robots and and cobots into our
workforce and and i think it's doing a
great service to everybody so thank you
and stay safe and stay thank you thank
you michael it was great being here
[Music]